in the years right before the move for
bayer to go purchase monsanto they got
approval from EU regulators as well as
the US EPA and USDA to go in with a new
genetically modified crop and nobody's
talked about this crop in the US our
farmers know it's there because we're
growing it in the Midwest already it's
called Liberty link and so it used to be
Roundup Ready crops from Monsanto but
now it's Liberty link from Bayer Liberty
link is a creepy enough name to it
anyways but Liberty link it turns out is
a different genetic modification to
allow for a different herbicide to be
applied to the crop and the mechanism of
action is same concept where it's
blocking the production of amino acids
which are the building blocks for life
but it's blocking a very specific one in
this case it blocks the enzyme that
makes gluten glutamine and and this this
happens to be an extremely important
piece of innumerable endocrine functions
innumerable functions of you know
cellular biology but most profoundly
perhaps is fertility human fertility
depend on this amino acid so this is the
this is the next evolution of roundup
this is the next evolution of GMO crops
and it's growing in your Midwest United
States right now and it's owned by Bayer
and so that got weird slice wheat it's a
it's a corn soybean now going across
they can put it in any you know anything
they want and at this point I think but
it's the big staple crops that they're
growing corn and soybean particularly
but sugar beets and all those are well
on the way you know so but corn soybean
already being grown in the US under this
new new crop treatment which is blocking
the ability of that food to carry these
essential amino acids into the into the
food chain so we have simultaneous
fronts on a fronts on our soil systems
and then we have the human health impact
of ingesting all of these crops on
math scale which is disrupting our
endocrine systems it's destroying our
microbiome like explain a little bit
about how this is leading to all of
these degenerative chronic illnesses
that we're seeing yeah
so you know I think to finish off that
political thought I just before my brain
can move on is it makes sense that if
you've got a new commodity that could
take over the majority of the world but
you're gonna indirect competition for my
with Monsanto who's already mastered 85
and 90 percent of the farm environment
to make the move to purchase that
companies a no-brainer because it gives
you the opportunity to become you know
monopolies across both it's amazing that
you passed antitrust muster I don't
think it got even evaluated I don't
understand how somebody could have
honestly said they did an antitrust
evaluation I mean I think when we were
here before the when you were here
before the merger was pending but it
hadn't fully gone I thought I was gonna
fail because of the antitrust issues I
didn't think there was a way that it we
not only that I just assumed especially
because of our current administration
having such a nationalistic you know
agenda apparently I couldn't believe the
last time we talked that it was gonna be
allowed to go through because what
American president would want to have
that on their track record that they
allowed 85 90 percent of art are
commodity crops be owned by a foreign
entity and it's patently
anti-competitive because there is no
competitor no competitor no competitor
and so how it could not have been
considered monopoly is beyond me yeah I
think they must have found some loophole
around that issue of well we have to
feed the world I have a feeling that's
how they started through well what is
the lobbying budget of Monsanto or Bayer
for that matter the GDP of a small
European nation
sure yeah and they're at multiple levels
right because it's not just food to
Mai's they're also also in energy right
because we've used up and raped our most
fertile soils in the United States for
the production of ethanol for our cars
and so Monsanto has been playing on
multiple sectors politically and so
they're not just food and AG they're
they're energy and you know spread
across into even military budgets I'm
sure because of the provision
ethanol to the military so and now it's
Pharma and now it's farmer and so you've
and farmers not new to Monsanto by the
way pharmaco own Monsanto auto back in
the 1990s and so when that when we went
to genetic modification of crops we
already were owned and our our food
chain was already owned by the
pharmaceutical industry by the time and
so Monsanto has been owned repetitively
by the pharmaceutical companies and so I
think Bayer is making the play now is a
big pharmaceutical company you own the
global food chain and make this weird
play for liberty linkage which is gluten
you know we're gonna block this amino
acid so now why have I never heard of
that if they purposely just not
publicized it and given it this
jingoistic patriotic name to make people
feel good about it well I think now I'm
predicting the future and I don't know
it but my prediction is we're going to
see a whole bunch of killer cases now
allowing to go to case to go to court
because I think bear wants everybody to
now admit that that GMO roundup crops
are terrible for your health so they can
pull it off the market quicker and look
like the white knights coming in with
liberty legacy well you're absolutely
right we see you know Monsanto who
refused to tell you this but we own them
now and we're telling you our science
and our review of all of their data is
saying it's definitely causing cancer
we're sorry Mia culpa and that puts an
end on all of the setting aside some
crazy warchest to settle all these cases
they had I'm sure they did because if I
mean look at how much they're making
just off of GMO crops that are still
selling Monsanto seed and so even if the
sixty six billion bought the company
they can there they've got the income to
them to offset the court cases without
they may have you know if you looked at
the amount of income expected from
Monsanto and multiply that by the
typical 5x for the valuation of their
company we might find that the warchest
was built right into that as a fudge
factor citizens they may have been worth
two hundred billion dollars and they
they sold for CG sex belly and said hey
we could pay a hundred billion dollars
of lawsuits and still at the end of all
that we pull that Monsanto GMO crop off
the market and we put Liberty link in
play and so they already have I think
there's no way a company
big bears not gonna have an endgame in
play when Monsanto is already all tied
up in these lawsuits
well the lobbying arm is certainly
healthy at this point I just got an
email today from ewg environmental
working group it was a letter penned by
Erin Brockovich about how how the farm
bill that's uh that's up for renewal has
a provision in it that would allow
locality that would strip away the
purview of localities to to ban
glyphosate yeah so this is still you
know this is a war that's being fought
constantly on multiple battle fronts
yeah I mean I've had people at the
municipal level at city levels begging
for our science to be taken to their
local school board to stop spraying the
school yard with Roundup you know and
you know are not are just our group
there's hundreds of scientists around
the world that are trying to help with
this mission but to see so much
resistance down there you know I got a
call a couple weeks ago from this woman
who was trying to make this fight and
they present all this science to the
school board and they brought in a
Monsanto sales rep to to be there and
the Monsanto's sales rep just got or it
pulled the Trump maneuver it sounds like
we're just got more and more angry the
whole time red-faced this is foolish
this this woman's uh you know has no
educational background she's bringing
all the science like she knows what
she's talking about baba doing this and
in his final closing statement was
roundup is so safe that I would be happy
for my son to lick the grass right after
it's sprayed and so as a scientist
having looked at glyphosate that's child
abuse yeah
that's flat-out ridiculous statement
knowing what we know about this but that
emotional argument overcame everything
and schoolyard still means sprayed with
Roundup and so it's it's the
emotionality of the human brain that's
one of our biggest challenges right now
and so we also don't want to really
believe that this is going on on such a
mask
like we want to just say there's no way
it could be that unsafe we would never
have allowed it to get to this point
we're smarter than that
certainly 98 the cover yelling the EPA
has looked at this there's been a
million trials everybody says it's safe
you guys are crazy conspiracy theorists
and I think that's been kind of the
paradigm for a long time and we are
seeing that shift you know people are
taking your point of view and the point
of view of so many scientists that are
allied with your perspective in a way
that we weren't seeing even a couple
years ago and I think that court case
you know goes a long way towards letting
credence to what's actually happening I
totally agree and I think the the
snowball is rolling that's why we've
seen this transaction for months and to
debayer
I think that the public sentiment as the
public continues to educate itself more
and more through you know open channels
will realize that we've known this for a
long time and it's no different than the
tobacco situation was in the 1960s to
2000 that forty years scientists were
trying to sue the tobacco companies for
lung cancer and for the damage to kids
immune systems and you know all kinds of
horrible things for 40 years that we
were at it you know with the data
coked-out is our products